a reporter fact-checked Donald Trump to
his face yesterday and Trump hilariously
seemed to sort of point at her or
someone else and then walk away let's
set it up
Trump lies all the time if you watch
this program regularly you probably know
that and one lie that Donald Trump has
been repeating time and time again is
that his administration's policy of
separating kids at the border from their
families migrant children from their
families is the exact same policy that
the Obama administration had Trump says
we're not doing anything differently
than Trump's than Obama's administration
was doing now in reality where I prefer
to live there's a major difference which
is that Donald Trump is prosecuting
people who show up at the border
including those seeking asylum as part
of a policy that's completely different
than what Barack Obama was doing so
Trump drops this lie in front of some
reporters and then CBS reporter Paula
Reid tells him that he's lying
he seems to either point at her or
someone else and then just walks away
not addressing the fact that he has been
fact checked in real time by a reporter
not a fake news person not an
anti-american person not someone who is
being partisan someone who simply says
that is not the truth these are not the
facts and Trump just walks away take a
look Paula Reid spoke with the president
about this at the White House President
Trump responded to the 16 minutes report
by repeating his claim that President
Obama also separated families so I'll
tell you what Obama had a separation
policy we all had the same policy
differently but Obama had a separation
policy but people don't like to talk so
this is what the media needs to do let's
think about this in a few layers this is
what needs to be done as I've been
saying to sarah huckabee Sanders Trump's
deranged and depraved SEC press
secretary at every opportunity real-time
fact-checking
not allowing them to get away with these
lies
the next question is whether this type
of fact-checking convinces any Trumpets
that trump is lying I think the answer
is of course not
because one of the most effective
attacks on American media in history has
been carried out by Donald Trump he's
used this guise of fake news as the
problem which has primed the pump for
his followers to distrust anything
that's remotely critical of Trump or
that Trump doesn't like but I still
think it doesn't matter Pat even if the
committed devoted trumpet is not going
to have their mind changed by trumping
fact check in real time the press should
be doing their job regardless of what
Trump's followers think and that being
said part of why it's easy to do that is
that most reporters don't do this so if
every reporter did this at every press
event it's going to become much more
difficult for Trump to keep up the fake
news narrative they'll try Pat but if we
actually had a sort of agreement among
the presidential press corps the people
that sit in the press briefing room the
people that asked from questions it is
gonna at least challenge the Trump is to
say wait a second why is he being
directly contradicted about all of these
things that he says maybe some of them
aren't actually true I do like that but
there is an optics issue I think because
of the power imbalance in that press
room like all the reporters are talking
to Trump and they're saying mr.
president
might I be able to ask a question or mr.
president that's not appropriate they're
asked they're acting with this level of
decorum and then Trump doesn't respond
in kind he'll call them fake news he'll
call them out he'll call them Liars and
I think a lot of Trump supporters see
that and are just gonna side with the
president and back him up at any at any
case yeah I mean the committed Trump
estat this point is effectively a
brainwashed cult follower I mean it's
like what we don't need to sugarcoat it
anymore that's what we're dealing with
you were dealing with a dynamic in
reaction to Trump as that is how
brainwashed devoted cult followers
behave but I still think that there are
people who can be reached there are
people who are going to be embarrassed
to vote for the guy that is
called out for lying every press event
and looks like an absolute fool and we
really shouldn't even be arguing about
what the effect will be because this
should just be the standard it's only
happening sometimes but this is how
every member of that press corps should
be dealing with Donald Trump and
remember that this there was that
incident with Trump's ambassador to the
Netherlands pete hoekstra he lied and
fabricated out of thin air that
politicians are being burned in the
Netherlands and that there are police
no-go zones what else was it that was it
that there were police no-go zones in
the Netherlands totally untrue of course
and he was called out about it by the
Dutch press and it was a shining example
of how these people need to be dealt
with that's what you've got to realize
when they get called out on the lies
they can't defend them they can get mad
they can walk away they can clam up like
they've lost the ability to speak all of
a sudden but every single reporter
should be doing this because otherwise
they can target the reporters that do it
if it's just Jim Acosta or whoever they
can target them and make it seem like
the problem isn't the press it's just
that reporter if everybody says we are
not going to allow him to get away with
lies we are not going to allow him not
to answer questions in a real way then
it might become much more difficult to
for them to activate against those
reporters without it being clearly an
attack on the freedom of the press which
is exactly what it is and another way to
attack the press is to say we are going
to take over the press with state-run
media and that's what I want to talk
about next